you've just agreed to the biggest deal
in tech history but big tech deals have
a history of going horribly wrong
why won't history repeat itself here I
believe the combination of Dell and EMC
are you know we have two highly
complementary companies we become a
leader in the current domains of IT
today's IT to servers storage
virtualization PCs we also are extremely
well positioned in the IT of tomorrow
digital transformation converged
infrastructure the software-defined data
center hybrid cloud security mobile so
this is a very powerful combination we
also bring together highly complementary
go-to-market engines EMC is well known
for architecting solutions in the very
top companies in the world and Dell has
incredible reach and breadth across
businesses of all sizes around the globe
the hardware route when some say that
virtualization is just a commodity well
virtualization is a lot about software
and one of the key aspects of this
certainly is VMware and if I look at our
research and development and innovation
emcs innovation it's certainly been much
much more software development over the
last five or ten years that then
hardware hardware plays a role but when
you build these ultra powerful converged
infrastructure systems there's an
enormous amount of software add to that
the incredible software from VMware
pivotal RSA virtustream VCE this is a we
believe a dream combination now there
are people out there who say this deal
is doomed it's doomed to make little
profit it's just an attempt to get scale
in a declining industry Georg colony the
CEO Forster looked you in the eye
yesterday and say said Compaq HP took
carly fiorina down you have to be
thinking about
you know I think we what I tell you
first of all is we spend about a year
working on this and looked at it every
which way and I'm confident that we are
building a incredible company I think
first of all you have just a whole
different dynamic as compared with some
of the other big transactions one
obvious difference is those other
transactions there weren't really
principles operating at the center of
the transaction so I'm all in on this I
think the level of overlap between the
companies is quite minimal and this is
not so much about combining existing
businesses there's a piece of that and
those fit together very well but it's
also very much about how we address the
challenges and opportunities our
customers have in the future including
things like security so you're taking on
50 billion dollars in debt to do this
how quickly will you will we see you
paying that off like how much a month or
how much a quarter as we've talked about
I think what you'll see is in the first
18 to 24 months a pretty rapid
deleveraging as as we you know go
through our process and we did this in
the first Dell go private and we had a
two notch upgrade from the rating
agencies and we're very determined to
take the steps necessary with both
revenue synergies some cost synergies
although the revenue synergies are
roughly three times larger to ensure
that you know this company operates with
investment grade policies so what
happens if the Fed raises rates I mean
how much does that concern you about the
risk you're taking on certainly that's
something you you you put in your model
and I think you know we've assumed some
of that but these range you can have
better guests that can help you figure
that out at least I hope you can but
that's that's not a big driver here
of what the Fed does within some you
know margin of outcomes so at the same
time you're doing the biggest tech deal
ever HP we are weeks away from them
splitting up and going in the opposite
direction what do you really think of
their strategy you know I think that
this is a business where scale matters
and we we have grown up in this industry
and seen the power of scale and
certainly the connection if you think
about what goes into the data center it
is microprocessors it is memory and it
is storage some other things but this is
the main component ingredients those are
also the same ingredients that you find
in client systems in the Internet of
Things in this explosion in devices I
think the scale matters I also think
that at the point where there is just
this explosion in the number of devices
the connection between all of those
nodes and the data center becomes even
more important